(applause)
- Ellen is joining us today!
- Hi, Ellen!
- Yeah, see.
- Yeah, she brought me a gift
(chuckles)
- I love Ellen, I did not bring
any televisions though, I--
(laughing)
I apologize.
- But you're an EGOT winner.
- [John] Yeah.
- So you don't need to bring anything,
you just show up and bless us.
(audience cheering)
- Uh, you've been, you know,
sometimes we trade favors in the business
and Kelly has been on my show.
- [Kelly] Yes!
- Trailer Talk.
(John laughing)
Actually, it's amazing.
- Trailer Talk is--
- I missed the Terry Crews one.
- Has a way smaller budget
than Kelly Clarkson's show.
(audience laughing)
We don't have any mics.
(Kelly laughing)
- We don't have proper
seating for our guests,
we only air it on IGTV, and uh--
- [Kelly] And you keep it real.
You keep it real.
- But we do sing songs together, it's fun.
- You do and you have all these people,
and I missed Terry Crews the other day
in the compound at The Voice.
- Yes.
- I was so sad, I love him.
- We sang Anniversary
by Tony! Toni! Toné!,
you know that song?
- Oh my gosh.
- [Audience] Aw.
- I love him, he's fun.
- He's fantastic, I love
him, such a good guy.
- Okay, but wait, I do
have a question though.
- Mm-hm?
- Because I feel like y'all travel,
every time I see you at The Voice.
- Yes.
- You're like, we just
got back from Japan,
we just got back from
Russia, we just got back,
but I'm like, geez, like how
are Chrissy and the kids?
How y'all doin'?
- Jet lagged?
- They're good, everybody's jet lagged.
Yes.
- Yeah.
(audience laughing)
- We just got back from Thailand.
- Oh my gosh, like, I'm telling you,
it's a different county,
it's not even like,
you know somebody's like,
oh I went to Nebraska.
(John chuckling)
It's like a whole flight,
like a whole thing.
- Well, I have gigs a lot of times.
- [Audience] Aw.
- [John] Yep, that's Thailand
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh!
- So, Chrissy's mother is from Thailand.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- If you guys wanna
follow her on Instagram.
She's an instagranny too.
(audience cheering)
- She's hilarious!
- She's pepperthai2 on Instagram,
but she's originally from Thailand
and we went to visit
Thailand for the first time
with the kids, they'd never been there
to see their grandmother's homeland.
And so it was cool, we got
to see some of the relatives
and we had a really good time.
- That's really cool.
I love it.
- It's beautiful, the food's amazing.
I ate some crazy things though.
- Oh, see I don't do that.
- I'll try anything and--
- I'll try anything, but like a tiny--
- I had a cricket.
- No, okay, I won't.
(audience chuckling)
Was it covered in chocolate?
- No.
- I'd eat it then.
(laughing)
- It coulda used some seasoning, actually.
(audience laughing)
It was all right.
It wasn't bad, my stomach's still fine.
(laughing)
- Wait, so Chrissy, the
thing I love about her
is she always calls you out on line?
- Yes.
- Like, she calls him out.
- All the time.
- Like, makes fun of him hardcore.
- It's so funny.
So what did she recently
do with the Insta-husband?
- Well, she made a post about
how no one ever takes
pictures of her on vacation,
and she was like woe is me.
(audience chuckling)
No one gets good angles of me.
And I felt like I was
being directly attacked.
(laughing)
I feel like I take really
good pictures of her
and she posts some of them,
and so I made a point of pointing out--
- [Audience] Aw.
- First of all, does she
ever take a bad picture?
'Cause she's super hot.
- Well, I don't think she does, but I--
- [Kelly] Good answer.
- [John] I make an effort
to give her good lighting
and give her good angles.
- [Kelly] That's a good man.
- [John] And so I--
(audience wooing)
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
(audience clapping)
- I posted these afterwards
and my hashtag was,
good Instagram husband, because
I wanted to prove because,
and Dwade, who's a friend of ours too,
a great basketball
player, he said basically,
when women get married now,
I think part of what they're
getting with getting a husband
is getting someone who'll
take Instagram photos of them
for life.
(audience laughing)
- My husband is so lucky.
- I agree.
- No, my husband is so
lucky, we never do anything,
they have to force me, 'cause I feel like,
I feel like I don't have anything prolific
or anything relevant to say,
like it's really hard sometimes.
- So, that's why you have a talk show?
(laughing)
(audience clapping)
- No!
Because this is the time
I actually get to listen.
You know me, I never listen,
I'm a talker, like so--
- You're doin' good,
you're asking questions,
you're listening to the answer.
- I am, I am.
Well, and I actually
want to hear this answer,
'cause I don't actually
know this full answer,
but, how did you and Chrissy meet?
'Cause I know we were on Duets together
and y'all were dating,
but how did y'all meet?
- We met in 2006, and it's
actually our anniversary week.
- [Kelly] Wow.
(audience cheering)
(audience clapping)
- What?
- So we met on the day my second album,
Once Again, was released,
September 13 of 2006,
and I shot a music
video that day with her.
- Oh, she was in it.
- She was the lead woman
in the music video.
And the guy who shot the video
is a good friend of ours,
and he knew both of us, and he
thought we might hit it off.
And he was like, showed
me a picture of her,
and was like, do you mind
if I cast her in the video?
And he was like, I think you'll like her.
(audience chuckling)
- I think he did.
- And I think I liked her,
and so we've been dating
since September of 2006,
and we got married in September of 2013,
so it's our dual anniversary this week.
- [Kelly] That's so cool.
- [John] And we're going to Paris!
- Oh yes!
(audience clapping)
All right.
Well, as you may know,
John and I are both coaches
on The Voice, which I've
won more, but it's fine,
no one's counting.
- She's never beaten me,
she's never beaten me.
- I have not beat him, but
it premieres September 23rd.
(audience cheering)
We also have lovebirds, Blake
Shelton and Gwen Stefani,
they're our other two judges this season.
What's been your favorite
part of the show this season?
- I love how deep the talent is this year.
- [Kelly] That was mine.
- I really feel like last season,
which was my first season,
I think there were clear
favorites that were really, like,
head and shoulders above the rest.
But this year, I feel like
the depth from the top half
of my team to the bottom half is like,
it's like, this narrow.
Everybody's really good and
really close to each other.
- It's no joke, it's the
best season I've been on,
like as a whole, all the
talent, it's insane this season.
- So good.
And we're havin' so much fun.
- We are!
- Gwen is really great.
- I know.
- Great chemistry with her.
- [Kelly] I had never
worked with her before.
- [John] Me neither.
- [Kelly] Yeah, it's really good.
- I never really spent
much time around her.
- I like how she reels the cowboy in.
- Yes.
(audience laughing)
- It's the best season
just to watch her be like,
Blakey I want this one, and
then he like gives it to her.
(laughing)
- It's awesome.
- He's a sucker, he's a sucker.
- He's a sucker for her, yes!